una ley veras dicta a los mandos
precisa en frances nicolas sarkozy
siete años de especies de ratas equestria y
los escándalos en el cuello también docomo el
caso bygmalion el ex hombre que eres tu
falso y condena a doha o al cordero de
pistas yonne polo financiero cioni legal
campo ser bogado yann siado quien
llamará a la decisión el presidente
sarkozy con quien hablé
o tal presidente de las bolsas tambien conocido
que carambar por telefono a los medios
lo que es naturalmente inesperado es
saint-etienne auxerre se puede escuchar
fue una adaptacion parece
sistema en denominaciones por corte
de la liga es intenso y es muy
buena oportunidad educativa hablemos de nuevo
elkins y debilidades de la espalda mil dos
y Sarkozy declara enfrentarse a la
aplicaciones tambien tiene goldman dato pierde
la pista tiene
decidido para la campaña bajo el equipo
multiplicar cuando sabemos este lote este
reunión en dos pero es sarkozy diot
misa de cuarenta discursos una media
cuatro por semana elle gastaud
maxim hodée venti dos como en santo
côme i lyonnaise heroes permite
hacer para una campaña presidente sial al
kanz cuarenta espalda como rastrojo alto
lyonnais este caso si ella dobley se va a
oculto lola un préstamo apuñalamiento mallyon
un marco de la organización de los lotes este
reunión falsificar factura colas como
sarkozy legal en belesta en un formulario
a la mochila si el embargo por al volante y 5
haddad el caso y el ex presidente y
se viste
nicolas sarkozy qo'nos camada hialina
legal de
gaza tenemos que eliminar la campaña en
icono de sol elevar burbuja
prescriptores de
Nicolas Sarkozy
es un fracaso de el segundo benedicto
contrato sarkozy el primer enfoque excepto
fo condena a la espalda después de su sobrina del coche
aquel donde nuestro duelo aumenta efectivamente
por corrupción y tráfico de influencias
eneyama de exploradores sin relajación
caza